This video is made possible by events.
Sero watches,
luxury handcrafted watches at fair prices.
You can check them out@vincesarahwatches.com forward slash biographics and link
in the description below.
It's the sad fact that evil men are often as well remembered as history's good
guys.
For every Abraham Lincoln or Gandy,
there are,
it doesn't Hitler's or Stalin's or dom has all Bundys or while you got the idea,
we've covered them a lot here.
A biographics tragic as it is to admit,
one of the most sure fire ways of being remembered is to make life a misery for
millions of people.
But what if we told you that was a man responsible for the deaths of tens or
hundreds of thousands of people who you've never heard of?
A serial killer who committed massacres,
rapes with impunity,
and to help us,
one of the worst dictators in history carry out his heinous crimes.
While not only did this man unfortunately exist,
he only died in 1953 his name was Lorenzi barrier stolons architect of terror.
The Fed had of Stalin's and KVD barrier was direct and you're responsible for
some of the USSR as worst crimes.
He took charge of an ethnic cleansing in the Soviet Union.
After World War II,
he rapes dozens of women murdered with his own bare hands and once sent over
22,000 people to their deaths with a single swipe of his pen.
In the video today,
we're looking at the gruesome story of the man whose name once made off of
Europe,
tremble in fear and how he came to vanish from the history books.
They say that monsters are not born,
they're made.
It's a comforting thought,
but it's difficult to square with what we know of this man.
When he was born in Georgia in 1899 it wasn't exactly into circumstances.
That screen this kid is going to be a massive minute era.
Young [inaudible] life was boringly normal.
His father was a poor farmer and his mother was a faded Nobel stock.
While his father would disappear from his life when Lorenzi was young,
runaway fathers don't normally create killers.
If they did,
Charlie Chaplin would be famous today.
Not for slaying them,
we've loved her,
but for literally slaying them.
However,
there was one other fatherless Georgian who grew up to be a mascara like
Lindsay.
He was born into rural Georgia to a poor family in the late 19th century like
Lindsey has father dropped out of his life at a tender age.
His name was Joseph Stalin.
Not that the two men knew each other in Georgia or anything is narratively
pleasing as that Stalin was over 20 when Lindsey was born in 1916 as the
communists from head to detonate a revolutionary bomb that would shake the
world's love.
Renzi was a simple nobody studying engineering and barker,
which is modern day as a genre.
It wasn't until the upheaval of 1917 February revolution.
That barrier even joins the communist party,
but to I'm joining of the Communist Party.
Well,
it would turn out to be a heck of a career move.
Barely was the ink dry on barriers,
membership costs than the tsunami of the October Revolution came a crashing over
Europe.
One of the single most significant events of the 20th century.
The October Revolution saw the Bolsheviks seized control of Russia,
bring Lennon back from exile and begin the entire process that would soon lead
to the Soviet Union for barrier.
This was a right place at the right time sort of deal.
The new communist recruit got enthusiastically involved in counter intelligence
in Pacu quickly becoming a useful agents.
He was there when the Russian civil war that exploded after the Bolshevik,
who swept into Azerbaijan in 1920 and in the chaos,
he was accidentally arrested as a counter revolutionary by the Red Army and he
was always sex accuse.
It only a timely intervention by the Azeri communist leaders saved him perhaps
the wanting to make sure he never wound up in such a precarious position again.
Barrier quickly moved to formalize his position as a Bolshevik counter
intelligence agents.
So he joined the checker.
At the time the checker was in the midst of the red terror series of massacres.
Same just anyone who didn't support a Lennon's dictatorship.
Somewhere between 28 and 200,000 died and number compounded by the simultaneous
white terror,
which targeted those who did support Lennon and kills up to another at 100,000
for agents barrier.
Now back in his native Georgia,
this was a fight to the death.
Well,
the,
the wise tell me had much of a presence in Georgia.
The real problem there was Georgia nationalists in the chaotic aftermath of the
revolution.
Georgia had declared independence from Moscow briefly in 1921 the Soviets sense
of the tanks in and well,
that was the end of that.
I believe it was for the army.
The men like barrier.
This was the exact time they would need it.
The most in the first few years of Soviet rule barrier helps set up a spy
network that's infiltrated and smashed to gangs of nationalists,
dragging that members offer execution or a long ride to signed areas.
Distant gulags promoted to deputy chairman of the Georgia and checker barrier
was key to crushing the failed and nationalist revolution of 1920 for a small
number of historians.
Even think barrier orchestrated the uprising himself to justify a violent
crackdown.
Whatever the truth here,
the checkout revolution,
it was brutal barrier cut a deal with captured revolt leaders to make supporters
lay down their arms.
Then proceeded to massacre everyone who had surrendered estimate some sketchy,
but as many as 10,000 Georgians never been executed on the orders of barrier.
Whole villages were wiped out in one grease in episode Checker,
operatives went into a town,
rounded up anyone with a satin sunning and guns them all down,
including women,
children,
and even babies not loan officer.
Barrier was out to a communist party conference flush with his recent bloody
success.
He was introduced to a fellow Jorgen Joseph Stalin.
Then still three years away from becoming undisputed leader of the USSR was
apparently impressed with what he saw because he had barrier.
They hit it off big time.
It would be the start of one of the bloodiest partnerships in modern history.
The next few years of areas,
life can be divided into two distinct categories.
Consolidating his power base in Georgia and furiously Brown nosing,
stolen like eight sentience suppository,
the butcher of Georgia.
Slowly it slithered his way up the greasy pole of power dispatching enemies
here,
sending innocence off to the Gulag there and other such things as his brutality
group.
So did his snapchat barrier rose to party chairman of Georgia where he
instituted a personality culture rounds himself that was based on Stalin's.
This was a remarkably difficult act to pull off.
Well limitation might be the sincerest form of flattery.
Anyone in the Soviet system who built a power base struck rival styling,
tended to do wind up with a terminal case of death and might've helped you that
barrier.
It was a magnificent suck up every time he saw style and he showered him with
praise,
he's your guy voted the dictators vacation security detail,
even built a holiday home next to style in his villa in a near identical style,
but of course smaller.
If there was one thing barrier knew,
well,
it was how to appeal to Stalin's vanity.
By 1934 barrier was one of Stalin's cheerleaders on the parties,
all important central committee and one of the Walrus mustache leaders
confidence.
He had been promoted to chairman of the entire Trans Caucasian region,
which is Modern Day Georgia as a bit John and Armenia for an average kid from
new as well.
This was probably higher than it ever expected to rise in his wildest dreams,
but barrier was nothing if not ambitious.
In 1935 he finally made his move,
the move that would take him out of the sticks and into Moscow's corridors of
power.
He wrote a book,
a book,
various ghost dressing on the history of the Bolshevik organizations and trends.
Caucasian was spectacularly doe.
Unless you happen to be at one of the major stars of its historical narrative,
get to guess who might,
oh,
fill those boots.
It's absolutely right.
Of course,
it was Starlin areas.
Book was essentially a puff piece,
kind of like reading a forming article in Vanity Fair,
but with much more bloodshed.
Unsurprisingly,
Stalin loved it.
The book's publication cemented barrier and his list of personal favorites.
In a few short years,
it would be the catalyst for barriers.
Next big promotion,
but first we have to deal with the great terror.
If the red terror was the warmup act,
the great terror also known as the Great Paj was the headliners taking to the
main stage.
While fireworks exploded and the crowds screams with paralyzing fear.
In this case,
all she did in 1934 following the assassination of Sergei care of it began as a
clearing of the communist party's ranks before ballooning into a general
cleansing of the entire USSR.
Random quotas were distributed in republics like trans,
Caucasian or ensuring anyone could be snatched off the streets and executed at
any time.
Scientists,
artists,
soldiers,
peasants,
foreign is ethnic minorities and more all wiped out.
Children of dissidents were shot for the crimes of their parents.
Today,
it's thought that a bare minimum of 750,000 people died with some estimating.
The figure is twice as high as that.
The architect of all this terror was a man known as Nikolai Yesh of the head of
the end KVD which had eventually succeed at the checkout,
but he [inaudible] he didn't work in a vacuum and the local republics of the
USSR and then like barrier enthusiastically followed his lead under barriers
watch.
Trans Caucasian became a sea of blood.
He used the purge to have old political opponents murdered,
tried to wipe out to minorities and settled Petty's scores with bullets.
It was a crazy horrifying time and anyone could have been next and barrier.
He very nearly was by 1938 years of was in a killing frenzy.
A friend of barriers in Moscow sent him an urgent message saying the n Kvd had
added him to the list of targets.
Terrified barrier did the only thing he could.
He caught a plane to Moscow and begged stolen for his life.
Various survival was not a foregone conclusion though.
For a couple of years Stalin had been hinting that he was getting bored with his
fellow Jorgen.
He no longer vacations near barrier ans while he had loved barriers book it also
not in through the disillusion of Trans Caucasian are taking barrier from head
Honcho of three nations to just Georgia realistically.
Very.
It probably had a 50 50 chance of stepping off the plane and somebody getting
shot.
Luckily it barrier landed in Moscow just to style and completely fell out with
yourself after indulging barriers.
Whimpered please.
For Awhile Stalin essentially said to barrier,
you know what's,
how about you take over as deputy heads of the end Kvd Alonsa only to yes off
and the,
and frankly only one of those guys counts because in a couple of months you're
going to have the other one to execute it.
Go on it.
And this is how barrier went in a handful of weeks from marked for death to head
of the end.
Gave Ed.
Yeah.
Itself was purged and barrier was placed in charge of ending the great terror.
Yup.
Ending it barrier may have been blood thirsty,
but he was not stupid.
Stalin wanted the terror to wind down so wind down it did.
Barea officially ended the purchase.
The execution's,
the exiles,
all of that stuff.
He released some prisoners and eliminated the use of purely sadistic torture in
the gulags.
If that seems a little off key,
think of barrier kind of like out of Eichmann.
The had absolutely no problem with unimaginable cruelty,
but what he hated more inefficiency and if you want to learn more about the
monster that was Eichmann,
please do check out our buyer graphics video on that.
I'll link to it in the description below and when it comes to a god torturing a
random prisoner just to get his kicks,
well that was a god who could have been torturing a known dissidence to extract
information.
It was simply wasted calories barrier ends in 1938 in a good place.
He had survived a purge that it wipes out a third of the entire communist party
had been elevated to head of the end KVD the most feared organization in the
whole of the Ussr and did done all of this while retaining his weird personality
holes in Georgia.
He also had Stalin's fever,
something that was no small deal when falling out with stolen men's being drags,
lock yourself into a freezing Moscow courtyard and shot.
So what does a man like barrier do when handed the power of life and death over
the whole of the USSR plus say get out of jail free card signed by stolen by the
way.
Well unfortunately for the rest of his countrymen,
we're about to find out,
cotton is a tiny community in the far west of Russia near the Ballah Russian
border in May,
1940 the Red Army slaughtered 22,000 Polish pow is there and dumped them in a
mass grave known today as the catty and massacre.
It was one of barriers,
most infamous actions as the head of the end Kvd oh and believe me,
the where other contenders barrier helped organize and carry out the
assassination of Leon Trotsky in Mexico City in 1940 he purged the Red Army in
the middle of World War Two.
You sending high ranking generals off to the Gulag in the dying days of the war.
He oversaw a mass scale ethnic cleansing program against minorities in the U S I
saw the most infamous of these was the deportation of the Crimean Tatars,
which killed up to 8,000 people.
There's,
it happens and another 20 to 30,000 when they arrived at the destination.
All this carnage and a barrier,
the nickname the Soviet hemlock,
but it's barriers,
unofficial actions that it uneasily today and his spare hours away from the end.
KVD and supervising the Soviet atomic bomb project barrier has a gruesome hobby
that he pursued with psychopathic diligence.
This hobby was being Moscow's rapist in chief after dark.
A barrier would be driven around Moscow until he saw a pretty girl.
His goons would then kidnap outruns,
bring out a barriers managing in the suburbs.
There area would wine and dine.
The unfortunate wench taker to a spare bedroom and rape are girls who've
suffered at his hand would be handed a bouquet of flowers the next morning as
they left the house.
Taking eds would mean the sex had been consensual.
Refusing it.
Well,
there are conflicting stories.
Most accounts suggest to girl who refused barriers.
Gift could see how families sent to the Gulag,
but there are other even darker possibilities.
In the 1990s the tuners,
he an embassy moved into old mansion while doing work.
They found the bones of dozens of teenage girls buried in the garden.
It seems barriers,
deviant appetites,
they did not stop with rape barriers.
Predilections where an open secret amongst the USSR sauce higher ups,
Stalin himself once told his own daughter to never accept a ride from barrier.
Nikita Khrushchev himself,
no stranger to murder,
openly both feared and loathed the head of the end.
KVD Yes,
barriers star kept rising and rising,
but some have even suggested barrier was the clear choice for the next head of
the Soviet Union in the event of Stalin's death.
So now you might be wondering,
well why didn't that happen?
Well,
in order to answer that question,
we need to skip ahead to 1953 to the death of Joseph Stalin
on the 1st of March,
1953 stolen was discovered on the floor of his share,
barely conscious and on the brink of death heavily for all those who believe in
Karma.
He spent the next five days and miserable agony before finally passing away in
his memoirs and Nikita Khrushchev wrote various spends those five days weeping
and kissing.
Stalin's hands when it looked like the dictator would recover and grinning like
a schoolboy.
When it's an oak,
it's like he was going to die.
Walker's chef isn't the most reliable witness to anything to do with his old
enemy barrier.
He may be right on the money here.
It doesn't worry me.
The barrier was falling out of style in his favor.
In 1953 Barea has long been suspected of secretly poisoning the dictator to save
his own skin.
Although no firm evidence has ever emerged,
weather barrier did the deed or merely benefited from it.
There's no doubting that Stalin's death find something in is with an old heart.
As an ethic power struggle erupted between Khrushchev and Malin called for the
now vacated throne barrier.
I've got the drop on them by doing something unexpected.
He transformed into a statesman in any ways.
The last hundred days of barriers life are the most fascinating.
History today remembers Khrushchev's secret speech denouncing style and in 1956
three years off to the Munster died barrier was denouncing stolen within three
weeks.
One of his first acts was to play the party's central committee secret tapes
that had recorded his conversations with style and to convince them as former
mentor had been Wacko by the ends before March,
1953 was out barrier how to unilaterally released over a million prisoners from
the gulags.
By April he had bans the use of torture across the USSR.
Shortly after that he returned to the passports.
There's over 4 million dissidence who'd been sent into internal exile.
It was a speed and scale of reform that left the Soviet world dizzy.
These work,
just the reforms that barrier actually got around to implementing under his
grand division barrier wanted to reunite east and West Germany and then that the
vote on whether to remain socialist,
he plans to tone down censorship and allow the various Soviet republics do forge
their own national identities.
Something that could easily have led to independence.
It's hard to believe,
but barriers,
plans for the Ussr Wa nothing short of an enlightened revolution.
So all of this now raises an interesting question.
How sincere was he?
Clearly barrier was an ambitious man.
Clearly he was also not that thrilled with the direction of Stalin's reign in
its last few years,
but as we've already seen,
he was also a murderer,
a sexual predator,
and a semi genocidal monster.
It seems hard to believe that the man who had sends millions to the gulags could
have secretly wanted to release them all along.
Maybe he was a real reform,
or maybe it was all a cynical power play to get the public on his side until he
could snatch the crown from Khrushchev and Mollenkopf.
In a great historical irony,
the only other reformer in Stalin's in a circle began to move against a barrier
almost as quickly as varia moved against him.
Nikita Khrushchev would go down in history as the Soviet premier who instituted
d standardization.
Yes.
In 1953 his only concern was removing the one guy as enthusiastic about reform
as he was for 100 days after Stalin's death barrier.
Khrushchev and Mallon golf jostled for power.
Finally,
it's something happened that flipped the cards and Chris,
Jeff's favor east Germany exploded in revolts.
On June the 16th a factory worker protest in socialist East Germany transformed
into a widespread uprising against local communist authorities.
Hundreds of thousands rotted across the nation.
Many more fled to west.
By then in the confusion of Stalin's death and barriers reforms,
the socialist authorities and east Germany had eased up on that hotline
implementation of socialism and now the people weren't open revolt.
It was all the excuse that barrier's enemies needed back in Moscow.
Khrushchev successfully blamed the revolts on barriers regime of liberalization
forcing an alliance with Malin cove.
Malo 12 defense minister Nikolai Bogan in Marshall Zuckoff.
He had arranged for Barea to be called in for a closed meeting at the end of
June.
What happened next is shrouded in mystery.
Khrushchev apparently read a speech furiously denouncing barriers,
crimes,
and branding him a traitor.
The climax was meant to be a signal for Madelyn cove to push a hidden button
summoning,
so you call it was men,
but in the heat of the moment he forgotten.
Barrier was able to beg his friends for his life before the officer's finally
rushed in.
After that,
everything's just speculation.
One version of the towel has it.
The barrier was dragged out to an anteroom and shot in the head before you could
even figure out what was going on and other hazards that he was smuggled out
posties own gods and brought to a grotty basement where men versed in NK VD
interrogation techniques tend to barriers own methods upon him.
Some say he was tortured,
others say he was simply in prisons before being pulled before a kangaroo court
tried and executed by firing squad.
The only thing we know for certain is that at some points between June the 26th
and does official trial on December the 23rd he was killed.
Many sources contends that barrier was dead long before his case went to court
and his trial was just a rubber stamp.
The actions already taken.
It said that his body was incinerated and disastrous scattered with a giant fan,
perhaps on surprisingly many of his end KVD associates,
what we'll say.
Rounded up and executed barrier had been stuffing the agency with loyalists from
Georgia for years and bloody purge of the whole outfit was inevitable with his
death barrier disappeared from history.
His name was scrubbed from Soviet records.
The mere mention of him was frowned upon his reforms that were addressed or need
to be partially implemented again by his old enemy Khrushchev just a few years
later today.
Those living in the west have barely heard of him,
but barrier left a peculiar mark on history or maybe perhaps a stain.
On the one hand,
he was personally responsible for hundreds of thousands of deaths.
He also raped countless women and was probably a serial killer,
is left millions of lives shattered and it's weak,
but he was also the first reformer to briefly lead the USSR and the first dad to
talk about desalinization with his reforms.
He could have ushered in a Thor in the cold war or he could have simply steps
the repression right back up again after his enemies when liquidated whilst he
simply amongst,
uh,
or was,
he may be something more as is.
So often the case with history,
the bouncer can sadly,
I mean he be,
we'll never know.
Now just before we end today's video,
I do want to take a moment to tell you about Vince.
Sarah watches,
I'm wearing one of these at right now.
This is a then Sarah chronic golf as well as keeping perfect time.
It's got a time of the three dials in the back there.
They look great,
but they also serve the function of a timeout.
I think talent's a watch with a blue and silver combination,
but there are loads of options on the website.
You will be sure to find something that suits your style and your risk size.
By the way,
I have tiny little risks,
so they sent me a smaller version of the watch.
So that was,
that's,
that's really great.
It fits perfectly.
Now I've been putting this watch through its paces over the last few weeks and
it's still looking as good as the day I took it out of the box.
Great,
durable Levon,
no scratches on the face,
anything like that.
It's really the king grant.
Then Sarah believes the luxury isn't about price or specification,
it's about detail,
it's about craftsmanship and then Sandra washes.
They have a lot of fat unlike many other watches on the market and Sarah isn't
about minimalist style.
It's more about that classic great look of a watch,
which is something I personally love.
I think this really sets itself apart from other watches on the market.
It's really a good looking thing further by selling direct to the customer of
Inserra can deliver a great watch at about a 10th of the price that you might
expect.
So go check out the full range of watches@vincesarahwatches.com forward slash
biographics link in the description below.
Also use the code biographics on checkout for a special discounts.
Thanks to Vince Sarah watchers for sponsoring this video.
Thank you for watching.
Don't forget to subscribe,
like all of that good stuff and I'll see you in the next one.